hello I'm cap I'm Dan we're the slow mo
guys and today we have a sprinkler
little sprinkly boy a little sprinkly
boy that you'd probably find on the
ceiling of a public place in there or in
movies or in a movie yeah most people
have seen one of these go off probably
in a movie or in real life if you've
been slightly unlucky but not everyone
knows exactly how they work so with the
use of these bad boys this one and this
one will show exactly how they work in
slow-mo these are not liked
yes I'll put them down there yes all
right then how do these work then
essentially what happens is you got a
fire in a room it's all burning hot all
the heat rises to the ceiling where your
sprinkly boys are what happens is this
little glossy juicy amp you'll hear the
juice in the ampule expands due to the
heat and that smashes the glass which
then lets the water flow through and
hopefully douse the fire this particular
one we've got here will hopefully
explode at about 68 degrees C or 155
American things yeah yeah Fahrenheit
thank you we'll start up here at a
thousand frames a second in 4k before
going a little bit faster to get that
glass break you got goggles I have got
goggles yeah okay I'll put them on
probably sticking one yeah okay we don't
have a fire in the garden so I'm just
gonna use this blurry flip a neck ah the
gas that's quite shocking quick it made
like a right popping sound good because
[Music]
you see the whole plateful yeah I just
like it was a good gun going
the way the hose is set up and the pipe
is like the thing is because it's so
what type like there was a little bit in
there in the trim so it like what okay
now we're good okay now we're going for
a cheeky top-down sort of like ceiling
view yeah yeah okay say when I'm in
position of the unfortunate fool in the
fire the only difficult years I have
this aiming the blowtorch away from the
camera I don't like that okay
say when I might aim down today okay you
ready yep
oh no all right well it's very shocking
every time it is every time I can't help
but like make a noise I tried not to
that time
jokes around that's so much air in there
yeah I feel like if you installed
sprinklers the fire would be fans
severely before right it's not my job
okay look that's a really good one you
can see clearly that we they're like
fans of the sprinkler they're causing
that pattern of water to go out
everywhere yeah it's just the metal
shape that causes such a widespread it
comes out like in a nice torrent and
then it pees out everywhere to the sides
it's good design don't realize it's not
just the glass ampule that goes this is
one that hasn't been fired and this one
that has when you look down this here
you can see there's a big hole where the
glass sample was on this one there's
like a whole metal surface that is there
so I think that ampule actually like
holds the metal surface in and then when
the ampule breaks they're like metal
disc drops and allows the water through
okay for the next shot we need a much
higher framerate so we borrowed this bad
boy from Destin the v25 11 and if you've
seen this camera before you'll know that
has very loud fans so sorry about that
okay we're now looking around this area
28500 frames a second get a bag the
camera because it could get a splash Oh
it gushes out there straight after the
red goes and the red goes flying yeah
you can see the amount of force that
blast is that thing down yeah it's like
a torrent of water after the glass
ampule bursts yeah it's like it pushes
the little plate down and then it's like
a full-on
torrent comes down the the turret is
much wider so it's much thicker stream
that I imagined I thought would be much
much finer stream but it's like so did I
I mean we're learning about how these
work and I can show you the plate that
sits there that the glass anchor breaks
them that's loose just completely falls
away and allows the loads of work very
all right now a much lower resolution
we're a hundred and three thousand
frames a second gets me every time
yeah it's like the pressure bursted but
we know it's the the liquid leaving
the regular crew comes out like sideways
and on the torrent just goes downwards
they're completely different
you see the red it's just come out words
completely later is that powerful of
birth yeah a little bit of air it's
mystifying
yeah I'm telling the steady guitar it
really kicks up it has a lot of recoil
oh yeah hard to see what I'm moving that
slowly that's who's been eating my damn
hammock I think it is he stood next to
the evidence as well return to the scene
of the crime have you look at what
you've done
it's pretty cute though I forgive him
make an episode of planet Earth
All Right see ya after feasting on the
hand of the possibly leaving it in
tatters
that was $79 down the tree I think he's
left some poo in the garden as well it's
not often that I actually get to use a
blowtorch and that causes me to get wet
that's true yeah also little red red
speckles all over your face a lot really
yeah I think you got some of the
glycerine I think that's good it's not
only bad not ideal I think it's like not
lead-free I like video so I like it
where you sort of learn it you can
visualize exactly how it works and now
I'll never look at them the same way I
can put on the smug voice if anyone
tries to ask me I'd be like nah I think
you'll find it's the ampule of glycerine
causes the explosion is a great word
it's underused amp pure and now because
you've experienced five explosions of
glass ampules you'll be less shocked if
they go off for real I don't think it
will be no you Wayne I definitely on
today's video hopefully you enjoyed that
video feel free to buy us a subscribe
that probably doesn't do anything hit
the bell as well if you want that might
we also got social media and a second
channel links in the description thanks
for watching